♪
>> Pete: IT'S BEEN NEARLY FOUR
MONTHS SINCE SHARON OSBORN WAS
FIRED FROM THE TALK.
OSBORN'S CO-HOSTS WERE FURIOUS
PIERS MORGAN ACCUSATIONS AFTER
HE CRITICIZED MEGHAN MARKLE MUST
BE RACIST.
THEN THEY THREW HER UNDER THE
BUS PAINTING HER AS A RACIST
DURING A SEGMENT ON THE SHOW AND
A CLASSIC AMBUSH.
BUT, NOW, THANKS TO SOME LEAKED
HOT MIC AUDIT YESTERDAY OBTAINED
BY THE DAILY MAIL WE KNOW THEIR
OUTRAGE WAS JUST TV MAGIC.
>> I KNOW YOU ARE UPSET.
I KNOW IT WAS TERRIBLE.
BUT I JUST HOPE THAT ONCE THIS
BLOWS OVER, ONCE WE -- THAT YOU
KNOW, CHERYL IS YOUR FRIEND.
SHE REALLY IS YOUR FRIEND.
>> I HAVE SAID TO CHERYL.
>> I DON'T THINK RACIST.
CHERYL AND I ARE HELD TO A
DIFFERENT STANDARD BY BLACK
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR OUT
THERE.
>> I GET IT.
>> WHO EXPECT US TO SAYING
SOMETHING ABOUT EVERY RACIST,
ANYTHING SIMILAR AND PUTS US IN
SUCH A POSITION THAT EVEN IF WE
DON'T HAVE INFORMATION.
IF WE DON'T EVEN REALLY CARE, IF
WE DON'T REALLY WANT TO ENGAGE,
IT FEELS LIKE A SPOTLIGHT IS ON
US.
YOU KNOW?
AND SO IT'S LIKE -- I THINK THAT
SHARYL WAS TRYING TO NAVIGATE
THAT LINE.
>> Pete: YOU KNOW, THE SPOTLIGHT
WAS ON IT HAVE TO THROW THEM
UNDER THE BUS.
HERE WITH REACTION HOST OF
"WATTERS' WORLD" AND AUTHOR OF
THE NUMBER ONE "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLING BOOK HOW I SAVED
THE WORLD JESSE WATTERS.
JESSE, CONGRATS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Pete: THEY WOULD LOVE
ANYTHING TO KEEP YOU OFF.
>> IF I DIDN'T GET NUMBER ONE I
WOULD HAVE TOLD MYSELF THEY
RIGGED IT AGAINST ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Pete: OF COURSE THEY WOULD,
OF COURSE.
THIS CLIP, HOW REVEALING IS
IT -- EVEN IF WE DON'T CARE,
EVEN IF WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING,
WE HAVE TO SAY IT'S RACIST.
>> IT'S A TAKE DOWN JOB, YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU ARE VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE YOU OUT.
THEY WANT TO TAKE YOU OUT, PETE.
YOU SEE IT ALL THE TIME.
THEY ARE COMING FOR YOU, IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS.
SHE WAS THE ONLY FAMOUS PERSON
ON THAT HE SHOW.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW ANY OF THOSE
OTHER WOMENNENS NAMES.
THE PRODUCERS WERE INVOLVED.
PRODUCERS, YOU CAN'T TRUST THEM.
I USED TO BE PRODUCER.
TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
SO WHAT DID SHE SAY, ACTUALLY?
SHE SAID PIERS MORGAN CALLED
MEGHAN MARKLE A BAD WORD OR
SOMETHING.
SHE SAID HE IS NOT RACIST.
THEY SAY HE IS RACIST.
SHE SAYS GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
THEY COULDN'T GIVE HER AN
EXAMPLE.
THEN SHE GETS CANCELED.
SO OZY OSBORNE, THE HUSBAND HAS
GOT TO BE THINKING I BIT A HEAD
OFF A BAT.
I WORSHIPPED THE DEVIL AND I
PEED ON THE ALAMO AND YOU ARE
GETTING CANCELED FOR THAT?
THAT'S CRAZY.
>> Pete: HERE'S THE OTHER THING.
WE HAVE ONE MORE PIECE OF SOUND.
BEHIND THE SCENES THEY ADMIT IT
EACH FURTHER WE DON'T EVEN CARE
ABOUT THIS STUFF THAT MUCH.
LISTEN.
>> I AM NOT A DNI EXPERT.
I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS GOING TO
COME ON HERE AND BE THE.
>> NO.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THAT,
ACTUALLY.
>> NEITHER DO I.
I'M JUST A [BLEEP] OLD WOMAN
THAT HAS A LOT OF STORIES.
I DON'T [BLEEP] CARE IF YOU ARE
AN ALIEN.
ARE YOU A NICE ALIEN?
THEN COME SIT DOWN.
>> Pete: I MEAN, THE MOB HAD TO
BE FED.
THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE GOT FEED THE
MOB.
THE MOB IS HUNGRY.
I DON'T BUY THAT OH I GOT YOU
FIRED, I DIDN'T REALLY MEAN.
TO SAY SORRY, I DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT I WAS DOING UP THERE
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
THEY THROW RACIAL HAND GRENADES
PEOPLE THEY DON'T LIKE AND BLOW
THEM UP FOR POWER.
>> Pete: DON'T ACTUALLY CARE.
>> WE ARE THE MOST LIKEABLE
PEOPLE ON TELEVISION.
BUT PEOPLE LOB HAND GRENADES ALL
THE TIME IF THEY GOT TO KNOW US
THEY WOULD LOVE US.
>> Pete: THAT'S TRUE.
HAVING GOTTEN TO KNOW YOU IT'S
MIXED BUT MOSTLY GOOD.
>> MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
>> Pete: MOSTLY PEACEFUL JESSE
WATTERS.
REAL QUICK, THE BOOK.
TELL US ABOUT IT AND WHY IT IS
SO SUCCESSFUL.
>> Jesse: IT'S A COMEDY PIECE
AND ALSO INTERESTING THERE IS
POLITICAL ANALYSIS IN IT.
THESE ARE ALL MY TRAVELS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY, SAN
FRANCISCO, NUDE BEACHES,
QUIZZING PEOPLE ON THE BEACH.
I FIND OUT WHAT MAKES LIBERALS
PARTICULAR.
IT'S THEIR INSECURITY.
WE DESCRIBE THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
WARFARE THAT THEY HAVE DONE TO
THEMSELVES AND PROJECTING ON THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY AND YOU
HEARD THESE STORIES ABOUT THE
TRUMP AND I HAVING DINNER AND
GOING ON AIR FORCE ONE.
THESE ARE HILARIOUS BUT YOU WILL
BE FED A LOT OF INSIGHT BUT ALSO
A LOT OF LAUGHS.
I GUARANTEE YOU THIS BOOK WILL
MAKE YOU LIVE LONGER, PETE.
>> Pete: REALLY.
>> LAUGHTER MAKES YOU LIVE
LONGER THAT'S A SCIENTIFIC FACT.
>> Pete: I THINK SO.
>> INDISPUTABLE.
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE AND BUY MY
BOOK, PETE.
>> Pete: A LOT OF PEOPLE A